how much it cost to get that free really
good weekend okay what's up everybody
how you guys been I just get oh my god
you're ruining this video right even
before it starts guess where we're at
today we are at booze Philly cheesesteak
out what's this Silver Lake Cape Town
it's like it's like that air something
but it's on like a fountain in Vermont
that area but check it out I used to go
to booze Philly cheesesteak all the time
they have one out in k-town I love Billy
cheesesteaks we're talking about beef
we're talking about cheese we're talking
this bomb ass [ __ ] hoagie dude and you
take that [ __ ] up on this griddle and
you take that bread and smash it on
there there is so disgusting what have
you been up to oh my gosh being a mother
sometimes she's like the worst mother on
earth every time I see her story I judge
the [ __ ] out of her yeah he's a great
mom she loves her child a lot she she
really does she loves her so much she
refuses to discipline her and teach her
things anyways we're gonna go inside
we're gonna grub on this food we're
gonna see what's up and kiss but you
know you're gonna get that [ __ ] back
in the kitchen footage and Ellen's gonna
let us know what she thinks about food
we're actually at the wrong [ __ ]
location rat the one they have two
locations there's one in Cape Town and
we're supposed to go to hey guess what
Jen I love that email where you sent me
the ADI to go here though I love you so
much but Jen
I [ __ ] hate your guts oh you know the
Lord loves you and I gotta say when
Jesus saved my soul
well you [ __ ] [ __ ] Wow you're out
do you have a Philly cheesesteak don't
write one Thank You Jennifer for sending
us to the wrong one
I like your communication style I like
how when I send an email you respond
back as if you never read the thing I
sent here great I love you so much
yeah no no no no no no I'm getting her a
shout-out I love you booth Philly
cheesesteak so I used to actually live
right over there and there's really
expensive ass apart when I first started
making money I was like I'm gonna fall
out it was the biggest mistake of my
life I can have that money in my pocket
right now and that's like a big
yesterday we're about to go inside the
booth Philly cheesesteak we bout to rub
on some shin
see what you guys want out of this place
because you know what I haven't been
here in a minute I hear that there was
some dope [ __ ]
I'm hungry yeah she's looking for a
husband by the way
oh my god
really looking for a husband that's why
she looks like a bot now Oh
edit this [ __ ] I'm a mother David how
dare you looking for some dick first up
my friends we have their steak and
mushroom with Cheez Whiz oh my god I'm
looking at this delicious sandwich right
now you could already tell that the bat
has soaked into that delicious hoagie we
have this delicious like sauteed
mushrooms nice and brown those savory
onions I'm gonna go ahead and grab this
first piece off real quick
and then you will get that other half
cause I know you're starving I am [ __ ] I
don't even know what the last time I
ever ate have you had a cheesesteak
before the Philly cheesesteak before
yeah but not like Oh Oh Cheers ah nice
and hot
I would eat no food so this isn't down
sweet onions sweet peppers except fatty
delicious beef that they put on that
[ __ ] hot ass riddled with a seared
off this right here is like everybody's
of light with their drunk as [ __ ] or
when you're just starving a [ __ ] and you
need something dank and delicious in
your stomach my god you guys
I won't eat no food
cheese wins by the way it's like what is
it
it's like Velveeta Chemical cheese I
love it it's so cluttered that it's like
American cheese a lot of people say it
like American cheese is real chief lucky
it's cheese all right down into darkness
open my eyes let me eat
when you're building my dad but I don't
know what it is maybe it's because like
our feet quality is [ __ ] over here or
whatever and you know I'm pretty sure
people are billions prove me wrong but
this is one of my favorite buildings big
spots it's not Delhi if I had any belly
it was delicious as well but maybe it's
because this was my introduction to it
this is my favorite
this [ __ ] is amazing next up we had
their pepperoni pizza fries how do you
feel about that vegan why you're afraid
about the poopy destruction yeah you
know what a little hard work never
killed anybody but I'm here oh look at
that cheese action don't touch my
[ __ ] cheese [ __ ] no you know what
this tastes like this is like [ __ ]
toasty nose man you know this kid I
[ __ ] love those deals Dumbo right now
yo get this right here though sometimes
right that nucleus cousin I'm gonna go
right in this [ __ ] right there
you know if you go back to not eating
meat you can't have this if you go back
to vegan you can't have cheese
I don't eat you ever one that's what I'm
saying tonight is gonna be scary
mm-hmm this reminds me of that [ __ ] like
when you're in college and you're like
highest [ __ ] drunk and then you'll be
dope if you mix the [ __ ] pepperoni
pizza with fries I said that dope then
you got that homie that was just like
you know what i'ma do it see what
happens they're like bet I bet you want
to do it he does I bet you I'll [ __ ]
would that's how you got this year right
here Oh got that spicy pepperoni the
cheese is super melty and salty you got
that crunch from the fries and just that
that little acidic kick from that tomato
sauce there you go you had your
vegetarian option right I know right
here we were a waiter Ricca but you know
what I do like I like when the marinara
like in the price so it's crusty here
but then it I walk four miles this
morning what did you do I had a session
with my artist your artist but your
artist um your boyfriend she keep saying
[ __ ] like that you know that she's like
all this she's like with my artist yeah
my work either your yeah
either your artist is your boyfriend or
you're talking about your [ __ ] because
you keep on talking about your working
at that session you wish but there is no
man out here I keep telling you I'm
taken already alright [ __ ] I'll let you
know if it doesn't work out you guys
already know before we leave a spot we
always have to make sure that we've
talked to the people that own the vision
and created this lovely place we got my
man Andrew right here
so Andrew before we go ahead and I go
ahead and start talking and blabbing off
why'd you let us know how like booth
started and how you got this big
scholarship so yeah basically about
seven years ago my parents Henry years
ago my parents moved to LA and they were
one of the first thing to ask me was
when I get
they got really sold just had she at
least once a week hoagies it's our thing
so when I told him that there is no
place out here that's good at all like
that one kind of on his entrepreneurial
streak it was just like you know one I
figured this out something like that and
it that wants money and you didn't know
about building a business in Los Angeles
so he started pushing a lot of stuff
with me and basically I just kind of
figured out how to open up a restaurant
and basically the study doesn't business
scratch so that's how we started about
seven years ago and you know ever since
Dennis has been kind of crazy we've got
three locations now gel interior of the
person wasn't certainly the second one
that the reason for my angle was kind of
just how we all started seven years ago
if you've never ever had a Philly
cheesesteak before just as a disclaimer
if you're looking for it to be healthy
like vegan friendly you want like these
to mange graze like chicken and gals hey
[ __ ] all this right
I want to serve I want some delicious
like sticking your gut type of food I've
had a lot of cheesesteaks in LA where
they try to do something different with
it but they're trying to make it light
and airy [ __ ] you did you know that if
you have sex with the lady they had a
child
you're literally a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're right though yeah I can't
wait on my [ __ ]
Oh last thing to say so the name booze
will occupy us where that name comes
from stand up to my grandma
Korean games in the machine so it's got
this kind of flavor to it
let's also my family so that's what make
comes from the best businesses in the
holidays and ourselves are simply based
on number one if you wanted to eat some
dope stuff that another that other
business won't make it so you create
yourself and that's how this place
started to grab my you don't come here
piece of [ __ ]
just to let you know if you're also put
this business straight up in your face
again oh thank you thank you sometimes
you thank you thank you Ellen doesn't
know what the [ __ ] she's done